if you want to know how team Curry's
Pennywise from the 1990 TV miniseries it
is hidden in his trailer then stick
around to the end of this video the
trailer opens with an overhead shot of
the town the same angle is also seen in
1989 and during the first movie here are
the two side-by-side for comparison we
then see the missing posters that are
piling up once again the town is
decorated with saloons in the background
possibly for the dairy canal Days
Festival which is the carnival in
celebration where it's makes a return in
the book we can't see the movie theater
marquee but in the first movie the
titles were accurate to the time period
so maybe in this movie it'll be showing
you 10 Cloverfield Lane
don't breathe lights out uh what a good
a year in the next scene we see someone
drowning in the sewers the first time he
comes up from the water he sees nothing
the second time there's blood in the
water and the third time there's a good
old friend who just woke up from his nap
nap and probably wants to play Jade of
the Orient is the same Chinese
restaurant that the losers Club has the
reunion lunch at in the book you can see
the words try me on this drink of the
Month advertisement is this a
coincidence or is this Pennywise saying
try me challenge me and see what happens
in the book Pennywise does manipulate
the dishes served at that lunch and
leaves similar messages throughout the
novel so I think it's a possibility the
shot of Beverly is brief but you'll
notice tall buildings rain a police car
and the fact that she's not wearing
makeup as she doesn't hurt other
appearances I think this is her late
night escape from her abusive husband
Tom Rogan the two lived together in
Chicago at the start of chapter 2 and
Beverly didn't have much time to grab
anything as she escaped everyone's
rushing to get inside but she's focused
on getting away from her abusive husband
like I mentioned earlier I think this
carnival as part of the dairy Canal Days
Festival and one room in the funhouse
contains a series of swinging clown
pendulums some of these look just like
Tim Curry's penny wise from the 1990
adaptation of it it has the yellow clown
suit orange pom-pom buttons and red
Tufts of hair there's a similar
reference in the first movie where a
Curry's penny wise can be seen in the
room full of clown statues this funhouse
scene isn't in the book but there is a
scene where bill and conquers a kid on a
skateboard and bill warns him not to
play around the sewers then bill gets
the urge to ride the skateboard because
the inner child inside of him is
essentially re-emerging so I think
instead of the skateboard bill relives
his childhood by going into the funhouse
maze and instead of him just warning the
kid maybe he saves the kid while he's in
actual danger also can I just point out
this is the sec
horror movie this year to have a mirror
maze bill trashes into this glass that
seems to be right in front of him does
it's maybe have the ability to change
the layout of the maze to drive bill
crazy if so it could make for some great
psychological horror when penny wise is
revealed the tongue is hanging out
further than we've ever seen it's kind
of like some weird smartphone filter I
think this is how it shows that it's
preparing for a meal because it senses
fear and feeds off of we saw this a lot
with all of the drool in the first movie
and I think this tongue shot is
essentially taking that to the next
level when the losers show up at the
house on 29 needled Street Eddie has a
bloody gauze on his cheek similar to
where Beverly has one as a kid and Mike
seems to have a wrap around his wrist
maybe a second coming of Eddie having
the cast in the first one and then bill
is missing from the group maybe he tries
going in by himself and the others have
to come save him in this next scene a
red balloon floats by this facility and
it seems to drive the inmates crazy this
guy has the initials J H pH on his back
the facility that Henry Bowers is kept
in during the 27 year gap in the book is
called a juniper Hill mental asylum so I
think for the movie it's been renamed to
juniper Hill psychiatric hospital maybe
Henry isn't the only mental case that
gets on its side this time also these
guys look like they're in a metal
concert these are the same three doors
that losers Club encounters inside 29
niebolt Street in the first movie but
one cool detail that I noticed is that
the blood is trickling up rather than
down just as penny wise is rising again
or perhaps floating back to the surface
now in the book there's a chapter called
walking tours where the losers go back
and revisit locations that were
important to them in their childhood
Ritchie goes back to city center where
he first encountered it Beverly goes to
where her parents house was and Bill
goes downtown maybe in the movie though
bill goes back to his childhood home as
well in this shot we see what looks to
be some kind of dream or a hallucination
with child Bill and adults bill
side-by-side in the flooded basement
either that or this isn't kind of
27-year challenge on social media in the
first trailer there's a shot of someone
splashing around in the blood and in
this one we see that it's actually
Beverly revisiting the old elementary
school bathroom where she was bullied as
a child the graffiti
clown has been crossed out
but it's unclear what it says under that
other graffiti includes greta Keene as a
[ __ ] Greta Keene as the movie
reimagining of a character named Greta
Bowie from the book in the movie she's
also the daughter of Norbert Keaton the
pharmacist who tries to warn Eddie that
his aspirator is a gazebo this small
text right here says Beverly Marsh gets
around which references the rumors
spread by Greta and her friends that
Beverly is this big stop censoring me
YouTube God there's also a good look at
the bruising on Beverly's arm most
likely where her husband grabbed her
during her escape here's another quick
Pennywise appearance in what I'd assume
is Beverly trying to break them out of
29 niebolt Street and then if you pause
near the end of the trailer you'll get
the only look we have so far at one of
the other forms of its it looks like
some kind of zombie like creature that
can swim can't wait to see what that is
maybe it's an undead version of Bev's
father here we have somebody falling
down the well and into this lights the
true form of it is something called the
dead lights which are teased at a couple
of times maybe what we're seeing here is
similar to what happened to Henry Bowers
when he was pushed into the well by Mike
for more on that watch my full video on
three theories for it chapter 2 or maybe
this is bill or Ritchie entering the
macro verse I won't put any spoilers in
this video but fans of the book will
know what I'm talking about it's one of
our last shots is penny wise shutting
this door back up to the surface the
only thing this reminds me of is this
one scene from the miniseries that isn't
in the book
take your pick a big berry boy you
should to let me know what else you
noticed in the trailer and flick the
video on the left to see my analysis on
the other trailer for its chapter 2
remember to subscribe to see these world
I've got a load of content planned
leading up to the next movie and I'll
see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]
[Applause]